before the world was created there was
nothing only night and day then emerged
the first two beings of our world from
night emerged the night man and day the
day man much is made of ancient cave art
and what it shows about our civilization
but what they have kept hidden from us
is the oldest conflict in existence
night and day and their soldiers the
night and day man one who wishes for
eternal darkness and the chaos that
comes with it and the other who sweeps
away the night and brings hope with
every new day naturally these ancient
paintings and engravings can be found
all over the world from the
Mesopotamians and Sumerians to the
Egyptians and ancient Greeks and they
have tried to hide this from you since
the beginning of time but luckily for
you I am here to tell you the story
who is they you may wonder and to that I
say I cannot tell you all your lives
would be in grave danger there is no
need to worry about my safety since we
last spoke the trash King has granted me
safe haven in trash topia where these
secret government agencies cannot reach
me where every man woman and rat is
treated like a god and where rivers of
coffee flow endlessly or at least I
think that murky brown liquid I've been
drinking his coffee anyway I'm in a safe
place now where I can share with you the
mysteries of the world and uncover a
generation of lies and there are those
out there who will tell you the knight
and Damon are just symbolic of the night
and day cycle it's just another story we
use to explain what we couldn't
understand and to those people I say
wrong what are you going to tell me next
now the earth is flat uneducated
buffoons
everybody knows the earth is shaped like
a trash can the night man and a man are
very real and definitely not another
made-up story based off a TV show it's
believed these two ancient deities
manifest every hundred years
choosing human avatars to continue their
ongoing battle I'm sure you're dying to
know who they are and whether they walk
among us today there are several
theories that I was able to find
the most common being that the Nightman
is actually M night Shyamalan but how is
this possible quite simple really
if we swap the names around we now have
night M what does the M stand for I hear
you ask the some may try and tell you
that the M stands for his name Manoj but
that is just ridiculous
everyone knows the M stands for man and
now we have night man so if that's the
night man then who is the day man again
another Hollywood star hiding in plain
sight
nice try Matt Damon did you really think
people wouldn't realize that Damon
really just means Damon it's actually
quite genius really who would suspect
Matt Damon of actually being the Damon
it's so simple and yet it took us so
long to figure out M night Shyamalan
sits there in his director's chair
trying to destroy Hollywood one awfully
confusing movie at a time while Matt
Jason Bourne Damon fights tirelessly to
prevent this from ever happening but how
does this make any sense you may
rightfully be asking and to that I say
how the hell should I know this isn't my
theory stupid and it can be easily
debunked M night Shyamalan is no evil
mastermind he's just an extremely
pretentious dude who makes movie so
stupid and confusing that he can't even
understand them himself and as for my
Damon how can he be the damon if after
they filmed the martian they left him
behind on Mars so he sits there waiting
for Elon Musk to bring him back so they
can film the 23rd Jason Bourne movie
anyway jokes aside and on to the very
serious part of the video
the Nightman is an entity that can be
summoned through a very intricate ritual
what is the ritual I hear you ask do you
really think that I am that
irresponsible that I would share this
extremely dangerous ritual with random
people online well you're damn right I
am the following ritual has been passed
down from generation to generation and
it was shown to me by a rather peculiar
looking man named Charles who often
visits trash topia a friend of the trash
King in a previous life or so I've been
told
to begin you must first peel an apple
red or green it doesn't matter
but you must remove the peel because
that is where the poisons are in this
Apple you must now carve your name for
the night men cannot enter our realm
without knowing the name of the one who
offers him the invitation now take your
Apple peel from earlier and place it in
a circle around the Apple now you must
recite the following just as I do night
man sneaky and mean spider inside my
dreams I think I love you you make me
want to cry you make me wanna die I love
you I love you night man once he is
summoned the night man will grant you
one request one wish but know this if
you do make the wish your soul belongs
to the night man and you will be nothing
more than a hollow conduit for his
darkness many have made this mistake
over the years once the night man leaves
them he wreaks havoc turning people
against each other and releasing their
inner demons his corruption spreading
like wildfire destroying neighborhoods
towns and cities in the blink of an eye
there is only one thing that can stop
the night man no it's not Jason Bourne I
already told you he's stuck on Mars if
you don't believe me go and watch the
Martian it's a great movie but ignore
the ending because that bits faked
everyone as Matt Damon is still stuck on
Mars and every movie he's recorded ever
since has been on a green
screen anyway enough talk about Matt
Damon I think you may be a little bit
too obsessed there is only one thing
that can stop the Night Man and that is
the day man
just like the night man he must also be
summoned through a similar ritual first
take your framed picture of Matt Damon
out of its picture frame and place it on
any surface
now you take account of silver spray
paint and spray a circle around the
picture now just like before you must
recite the following Damon fighter of
the night man champion of the Sun you're
a master of karate and friendship for
everyone once summoned they will find
one another for they drawn to each other
like moths to a flame like flies to [ __ ]
like Matt Damon to Mars like the trash
man to Starbuck I think you get the
point once they have found each other a
fight to the death ensues but the
outcome is always the same the night man
is well-versed in karate but the day man
is a master and always emerges
victorious though his victories
short-lived because if one dies so does
the other and so the cycle repeats
itself the night man is summoned by some
poor schmuck who doesn't understand the
wish is never worth the price and once
he's done of them he roams the earth
freely there has only ever been one to
summon the night man and survive the
encounter though he was never the same
this is the story of a boy named froggy
the Frog kid there was once a boy named
froggy we know him as the Frog kid
because well he looks like a frog his
skin was wet in the slimy and his eyes
bulged from his head like Mesut özil
froggy had been called every name under
the sun from frog eyes to frog face to
even toad boy and my personal favorite
[ __ ] froggy alliteration always
makes insults better and children can be
so mean and creative froggy would often
have to pour water over himself to keep
his skin hydrated but the other kids
would throw salt and watched as for he
screamed in pain and dried up like a
prune while they chanted [ __ ] froggy
[ __ ] froggy froggy wished he could
be a normal boy but life isn't always
fair one day after school on his way
home
froggy came across a man wearing a black
suit and sunglasses with a rather odd
briefcase the symbol of a golden tree
etched onto it
the man paused looked at froggy and
opened the briefcase he took a piece of
parchment and handed it to froggy he can
help you
the man whispered of an ear-to-ear grin
on his face when he got a home froggy
opened the piece of parchment and
written on it was a set of instructions
under the heading the Nightman cometh
froggy remembered the man's words he can
help you and so he began to peel his
Apple and on that Apple he wrote his
name his real name Frank he recited the
words as they were written and when he
was done he felt strange there was a
darkness pulsating through his body his
head his arms but mostly his anus all of
a sudden his curtains drew themselves
shut and when he turned around there he
was a shadowy figure that towered over
him
it was the Night Man what do you desire
the figure snarled froggy took a moment
to compose himself I want to be a normal
boy the night man nodded the price is
your soul confused and with his anus
still pulsating froggy shrugged his
shoulders I guess you can have my soul
the night man put his hand on froggies
forehead and channeled his darkness he
could feel something changing his eyes
began to shrink to a normal human size
when he looked down at his arm
his skin was no longer slimy turning to
face the mirror
froggy saw a normal boy and began to
laugh but the night man's facial
expression did not change
your soul young man the night man
demanded but froggy was confused how was
he supposed to give him his soul I don't
understand
froggy replied turn around and bend over
I will extract the soul myself
froggy did as he was told the night man
inserted his hand into froggies anus and
began to rummage around a rather strange
sensation but froggy figured if souls
were real then why wouldn't they be
located in one's anus the night man
began to laugh and for the first time
his facial expression changed he must
have seen or felt something inside of
froggy that he liked he removed his hand
rather abruptly you can keep your soul
boy you are destined for greatness you
will be known as before the shadowy
figure could finish his sentence the
curtains opened and through the window
came a figure dressed in yellow with a
top hat and a cane in one swift kick the
shadowy figure crashed through the
window and the man in yellow turned to
face froggy and said you got to pay the
troll toll to get in that boy's hole and
as quick as he appeared he was gone
those words would resonate with froggy
for a long time after that night froggy
was never bullied again and he went by
his real name the trouble is he told
people his story his insane story of a
shadowy figure who shoved his hand in
his anus and the man dressed in yellow
talking about a boys Hall Frank was then
to be committed to the local mental
asylum but he ran ran as fast as he
could until he came across a man named
Pablo who offered him a ride to Tijuana
with no family or anyone to care for
young Frank he resorted to search in
dumpsters for food and surprisingly
enough they made a rather comfortable
bed the years went by and Frank had
grown accustomed to his life of dumpster
diving to the locals he was the crazy
man who wouldn't shut up about a frog
being molested by a nightmare
and saved by a daemon incoherent
gibberish from a man a boy who had
suffered some kind of trauma a made-up
coping mechanism or maybe Frank had
found himself in the middle of a battle
that had been raging since the start of
time one thing was for sure Frank was
not destined for greatness he'd never
amount to anything sifting through trash
no one would ever know the name Frank
Reynolds
they took unite man and you don't belong
to them
and they left me in a world of darkness
without your sexy hands and I miss you
night man so bad day man Oh Matt Damon a
bit seriously guys everyone has the
message Elon Musk to hurry up and get
Matt Damon off Mars because it's very
serious
we need him we need more Jason Bourne
movies please thank you I've been your
host Matt Damon explained